this is not 2017.
i understand the importance of andrew
luck are you kidding me this guy's one
of the top five quarterbacks in the
league but we also got another
quarterback that we like in jacobi reset
so i mean that to me that's part of
building a team you know you've got to
be able to handle when things don't go
the way you plan them out to be um i
think if you asked andrew you asked any
of us that do we wish you would have
gone through the spring and been pride
yeah absolutely but that's just not
where we're at we're
this is where we're at we think we've
got a handle on it and we'll treat it
and we'll move forward we'll deal with
whatever we have to deal with going
forward
chris ballard colts gm friend of the
program last night conference call with
reporters addressing the confusion that
has emerged regarding the andrew luck
injury it was a calf strain since april
chris calf strain calf strain cash
training three mris calf strain what's
wrong with this calf it's strained okay
fine then on monday it was
jim irsay the owner of the colts saying
that there's a small little bone issue
with andrew luck which caused us to say
what the hell is going on here and now
chris ballard further explanation a high
ankle issue a question of whether or not
there is an injury to the os trigonum a
small bone located behind the ankle
which at one time was believed to be a
possibility for luck now they are
focusing on it again tests show the
quarterback does indeed have a strained
calf but the team believes to have
isolated the issue to the front of his
left ankle which has caused pain in the
area for months chris how does it take
so long we talked about this yesterday i
think on pftot you can take your car to
a shop they plug it in they know what's
wrong how in the hell does a 25 million
a year quarterback not have a similar
device available at a football facility
state-of-the-art billion dollar business
to find out what the hell's wrong with
the guy because this is the the way it
is in the nfl mike you hear me complain
about this all the time and i don't it's
not only from me it's from players
across the nfl that i talk to about this
issue you know the nfl's answer to
everything is ice and stim ice and stem
that's great but that's been around
since my dad was getting ice and stim in
1984 okay there's other there's no
matter what your injury is oh you hurt
your neck we'll ice it and then stem it
oh you uh hurt your hip we'll ice it and
then stim it i mean that that's that
it's very
uh i don't you know basic
for the year of 2019 and what's out
there and what's to be had i'm confused
as hell by what's going on there right
now i mean was the calf injury we know
it's real okay i mean they're standing
by that but did he hurt his ankle you
know doing his own drills you know
inside the indoor practice facility
maybe when he was lightly dropping back
uh or was this something all along is it
a bone spur i mean there's just this is
a crazy one to me and the fact that
chris ballard i'm just going into my
like psychic here that he brings up you
know out of nowhere hey we have a backup
quarterback in jacoby versette who we
believe in and team building that right
there that comment just opened the door
a little bit for me to go hmm is he
trying to like calm everybody down and
go we'll be okay in week one with jacoby
percet i don't know but those are just
the things that go through my brain when
i you know try to connect all the dots
here
ballard said it's too early to rule luck
out for week one but this has been
lingering since april he's only
practiced three times and here's the big
difference because ballard
got lucky well and i don't think it was
luck i think it was good knowing a
couple of years ago to get jacoby
brissette he came right in and played
well right this time around jacoby
brissette's got the benefit of taking
all those reps that andrew luck hasn't
been able to take if luck has only
practiced three times since april
brissette has been the one who has
benefited from luck's absence so he's
going to be far more prepared to run
that offense this year than he was two
years ago when he ran it pretty well he
did so i i i'm intrigued by that
possibility and i'm fascinated by what
brisette can do with the opportunity to
prepare but i think you're on to
something chris
chris ballard doesn't need to start
saying oh dude we're fine with jacoby
brissett we have faith in brazen unless
he's come to terms with the very real
possibility that's going to be beset
week one when they take on the chargers
yeah you know again i don't know that
but it just you know one of those things
i acknowledged in the statement where i
went hmm okay he brought him up and
talked about that that's that's a little
interesting to me uh the points you make
about jacobi percent mike i mean yes
good job spot on i mean what he had to
uh deal with coming into the building
and basically six seven days whatever it
was eight days later he's the starting
quarterback and running an offense that
he has no clue about
one shows his ability to pick up an
offense two shows his ability that he
can play because he couldn't have been
always comfortable in making every right
read in every decision but somehow he
was getting it done uh and the point you
made about him having all those reps
that's real that really is i mean this
is the great thing about having a backup
quarterback when you have a team that's
in the super bowl conversation your team
can still be in that conversation when
you have a jacobi percep because he is
an nfl starting level quarterback is he
as good as andrew luck no but he is an
nfl starting level quarterback i mean
i'd rather have jacoby beset than eli
manning i'm not trying to take a shot
there or some of the other guys that are
low level you know starting quarterbacks
at this point of their career or
whatever it may be
so that's very encouraging for that team
and i don't think there'll be a whole
lot of slippage if jacoby does have to
play
hey we started down this rabbit hole
yesterday just kind of speculating and
having some fun about where things would
go from here if brisette plays the bulk
of the season hits free agency would the
colts franchise tag him and keep him
around you got 22 million going to
andrew luck next year it would be 25
million to keep her set for one more
year
and
number one you're keeping around a guy
who is a starting caliber quarterback
and number two you need that insurance
against the possibility that andrew luck
can't play
and colts fans should be saying hey jim
irsay trade in the pink floyd guitar
sell the john lennon piano get that 25
million dollars together that cap space
you guys have been hoarding and keep
jacobi brissette even if it takes the
franchise tag and better yet go to him
now with a pile of money make him an
offer he can't refuse he's
self-represented pounce on him get him
under contract for 10 million a year now
so you've got him for the next three
seasons at a minimum while andrew luck
is still your starting quarterback yeah
well you know another thing that went on
you know the last you know month or so
remember frank reich he came out and
said like man i love jacoby brissett i'm
wishing for the best of him i mean he
kind of insinuated too that the guy is a
starting nfl quarterback uh and i think
ultimately that's what the dream is for
jacoby he hopes he can be the backup if
he's got to play play well and he can go
somewhere next year and have a chance to
be a starter and
good for him he's done everything right
and he's got the right supporting cast
there to make it happen and make himself
look good if that does happen
and frank reich is the right head coach
to handle this he's made it clear he's
not going to get flustered by luck being
injured and it's easy to not get
flustered when you have a backup
quarterback that you fully and
completely believe in not many teams can
say that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports